the academy proudly presents a technical
Achievement Award to Sebastian tugi and
Christoph Zoom for the concept and
original implementation of substance
engine and to Silvan Paris and Nikola
virgman for the design and Engineering
of substance designer
[Music]
thank you very much good evening
everyone first we would like to thank
the academy for the recognition it's an
incredible honor to be here tonight and
see the work we've done being recognized
as having had an impact very significant
impacts on the very Arts of her
Motion Pictures and signs of Motion
Pictures we're all passionate about
sorry now we want to thank the entire
substance designer team past and present
core and extended and the whole team at
the algorithmic and now Adobe for making
this possible
today only four people are on stage but
in reality we all know it takes a
village so thank you all again
uh we also thank you
we also want to thank the community of
artists who pushed the tools to their
limits and helped us tremendously in
this journey as a personal note this
feels very special and full circle to me
as a long time ago I tried to enter a
film School in Paris and got rejected
I wanted to become a director but
instead I pivoted to science which
eventually led me to create a
logarithmic so I did not create movies
myself but with substance designer the
team and I we participated in helping
many creators and dreamers
materialize their vision and that is
something I could not have imagined
my PhD advisor the math genius at the
heart of the substance noise functions
who's so Beauty in my bugs and invited
me to explore further
and to these guys around me because well
you rock I finally dedicated this to
dedicate this to my parents to my dear
spouse Leticia and my two boys Mela and
Vito love you
thank you
wow
I would like to especially thanks the
superstars designer team I am working
with every day
thank you to the amazing community of
artists
we have created this software for you
and we will continue to develop it for
you
I also want to thank my parents my
sister my wife and my daughter for their
unconditional support and patience
finally I want to express my deep
gratitude to you Sebastian here
for bringing me into the incredible ship
song story thank you very much
uh this Awards comes at a perfect time
because exactly 20 years ago I was hired
by Sebastian yeah
and I start to develop the Prelude of
what would become substance in my
student room in France
and tonight 20 years later I'm giving a
speech in front of the academy it's
quite well
20 years of an incredible Adventure Time
perseverance space and loyalty pace
first
developing tools for artists is a real
passion
it's my fuel and I want to extend a
special thanks to all the technical
artists
that contribute to substance
we work only in and it's extremely
fulfilling extra instructive motivating
and the result is here
thank you and finally I want to dedicate
this award to my wife Charlene
hello
what an incredible journey I dedicate
this award to the talented people I work
with every day you've made these past 15
years working on this software I will
join
to the incredible community of artists
and Technical artists using substance
designer seeing what you have to achieve
with it is the most rewarding thing we
could imagine
please keep pushing the limits and
please keep challenging us
to my wife Charlotte for your continued
support I love you and thank you Seb
for your trust your leadership and your
generosity thank you
thank you